we've just got some breaking news to  bring you and Brent Renault an American  photojournalist has been killed while  working in Ukraine he had previously  contributed to the New York Times  earlier Cliff Levy the deputy managing  editor of the New York Times wrote this  on Twitter we are deeply saddened to  hear of Brent renner's death Brent was a  talented photographer and filmmaker who  had contributed to the New York Times  over the years that we had contributed  to the times in the past most recently  back in 2015. he was not on assignment  for any desk at the times in Ukraine  early reports that he worked for the  Times circulated because he was wearing  a times press pads that had been issued  for an assignment many years ago so the  news that a photojournalist Brent  Renault from America has been killed  while working here in Ukraine